[Music]
have you ever been frustrated that you
couldn't just link an account to a 3ds
or Wii U and redownload your old games
well you're not alone but it sounds like
you'll be able to do that with the
Nintendo switch
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more coverage of Nintendo's new console
Eurogamer reports that the Nintendo
switch will tie digital purchases to an
account not a specific piece of hardware
which is how it worked with the 3ds and
WiiU and in a recent Nintendo switch
unboxing video a lot of texts can be
seen that explains how games can be
redownload adduce in the same account
your Nintendo account contains your
Nintendo eShop purchase history and
current balance by real inking your
Nintendo account after initializing the
console it will be possible to
redownload any software or DLC purchased
using that account software has been
discontinued may not be available to
redownload in some cases the Nintendo
switch releases on March 3rd in addition
to several launch titles including The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild one
to switch and the binding of issac
afterbirth Plus and if you can't wait
that long then you're in luck Nintendo
recently stopped by GameSpot and now
we've got a bunch of one to switch
videos for you to check out